hi there i saw this article in ieee
spectrum called deep learning's
diminishing returns the cost of
improvement is becoming unsustainable
this is by neil c thompson christian
greenwald kihon lee and gabriel f monso
and i thought it was an interesting read
because it talks about the computational
limits that we're reaching with deep
learning today and i have it over here
in
annotatable form though it might not
look as pretty i think the article it
leads up to the point where it shows
just how much compute will be needed to
make further improvements in deep
learning and what the consequences of
that might be and some of the ways that
people are trying to get around it now i
i don't agree with everything the
article says but i think it's a it's a
pretty neat read it's pretty short so i
thought we can talk about it a little
bit so the article starts out with
essentially praising deep learning for
achieving so many things for example
translating between languages predicting
how proteins fold and many other things
playing games as complex as go they say
it has risen relatively recently but it
has a long history they mentioned 1958
and frank rosenblatt at cornell
designed the first artificial neural
network they say rosenblatt's ambitions
outpaced the capability of his era and
he knew it apparently he said as the
number of connections in the network
increases the burden of a conventional
digital computer soon becomes excessive
so why are deep neural networks working
because of course computers have
increased in power massively just for
computing power there has been whatever
a 10 million fold increase according to
moore's law and that's usually just
measured in something like cpu
instructions and now we went even beyond
that building special purpose hardware
such as gpus which aren't actually
special purpose for this but also tpus
so they say these more powerful
computers have made it possible to
construct networks with vastly more
connections and neurons and hence
greater ability to model complex
phenomena and of course these are the
deep neural networks that power most of
today's advances in ai they draw a
comparison right here they say like
rosenblatt before them today's deep
learning researchers are nearing the
frontier of what their tools can achieve
essentially claiming that we are in a
similar situation today we have the
models that can achieve things and we
know pretty much that scaling them up
can increase performance however we're
kind of at the limits of how much we can
scale for example i reported on this
that sam altman apparently said gpt-4
will not be much bigger than gpt-3 it
will be trained more efficiently will
have some smartness in it on how it's
processed it will use more compute but
it will not necessarily be that much
bigger in scale so the first thing the
article touches about deep learning is
the fact that deep networks are over
parameterized for example the noisy
student model has some 480 million
parameters yet is trained on only 1.2
million labeled images which is the
imagenet data set now of course the
noisy student model if i understand
correctly also may leverage unlabeled
data but granted today's neural networks
are massively over parameterized they
have more parameters than data points
available therefore they should horribly
overfit but they don't they say
classically this would lead to
overfitting where the model not only
learns general trends but also the
random vagaries of the data i was
trained on deep learning avoids this
trap by initializing the parameters
randomly and then iteratively adjusting
sets of them to better fit the data
using a method called stochastic
gradient descent surprisingly this
procedure has been proven to ensure that
the learned model generalizes well now
i'm pretty sure that we are not yet sure
why exactly deep networks don't overfit
or why they generalize as they get over
parameterized i know there are some
proofs around sgd and so on but these
proofs usually require assumptions that
just make them completely lose touch to
reality but the core message is true
deep networks are over parameterized and
that is probably one of the reasons why
they work so well and being over
parameterized they are quite flexible
they say at the good news is that deep
learning provides enormous flexibility
the bad news is that this flexibility
comes at an enormous computational cost
this unfortunate reality has two parts
they say the first part is true of all
statistical models to improve
performance by factor of k at least k
squared more data points must be used to
train the model does this really hold
for all statistical models is this from
the same theory that says the
statistical models should overfit when
they're over parameterized i'm not sure
the second part they say of the
computational cost comes explicitly from
over parameterization once accounted for
this yields a total computational cost
for improvement of at least k to the
fourth power meaning for a ten-fold
improvement you would need to increase
the computation by 10 000. now
regardless of whether you think the
theoretical analysis is actually
accurate here again this is from the
same area that says these models should
overfit horribly it doesn't matter
because these people have actually
collected data and they say theory tells
us that computing needs to scale with at
least the fourth power of the
improvement in performance in practice
the actual requirements have scaled with
at least the ninth power so when you
actually measure how much people need to
scale computation in order to achieve a
given performance then it's actually
it's much worse than the theory predicts
in fact they have these neat graphs
right here so on the left you can see
the percent error i believe this is the
imagenet classification data set and on
this axis you can see the time now here
you can see that over time as time
progresses the error has come down and
down and down again as new
state-of-the-art models were proposed
ever since the 2012 success of alexnet
and if you extrapolate that you can
pretty clearly see that around 2025 we
should be at approximately 5
of error see i thought you'd had to
actually do something to reach a new
state of the art on imagenet but as it
turns out we just need to sit here and
wait until 2025. okay jokes aside uh
they overlay this graph with another
graph right here and that is the
comparison of again percent error on the
y-axis but now it's not the year in
which the achievement was made but it is
number of computations in billions of
flops and notice the log scale down here
now i have to say this graph right here
makes it pretty clear that there might
be something like a relationship even
maybe a linear relationship that you can
extrapolate right here i'm not so sure
like these models are up here and then
goes like here and then it goes here and
then it goes here and then it goes over
here to 2020 and really without that you
probably have a line that goes something
like this now in any case if they do
actually the line that they're doing
then you can see that if you extrapolate
the same thing to this five percent
error rate you do end up at something
like 10 to the 18 flops and they also
compare this to the equivalent carbon
dioxide emissions for example right now
we are somewhere between the co2
generated by the average u.s resident in
one year and the co2 generated by the
average u.s resident in a lifetime the
current models somewhere in between to
train them once if you actually
extrapolate this to the five percent
error rate to the 10 to the 18 flops
then it becomes suddenly co2 generated
by new york city in one month so the
entire city of new york city for one
month is the same as gpus go br
to train imagenet now that is pretty
shocking i have to say you know it
checks out they have done the research
they extrapolated correctly here and
they come to this conclusion the co2
equivalents i'm sure they are measured
correctly and so on i do have several
problems with this though the first one
i already said the zigzag in this graph
right here doesn't really suggest that
you can simply extrapolate over these
advances also the 2020 point seems to be
quite out there so if there was any
architecture search involved if there
was any giant pre-training involved or
anything like this i'm sure like that
that adds to the co2 emissions but it
doesn't say that you cannot achieve the
same thing with something else so
whether the slope of the line is really
the black one right here or more like
the blue one i drew it makes quite a bit
of a difference actually makes an
exponential difference so i'm a bit
doubtful that you can really pinpoint
this five percent error point two five
years in advance okay it's 20 22 now so
three years but still and speaking of
co2 equivalents not all energy is equal
for example google prides itself in
being zero emission therefore if google
trains a model there is no co2
equivalent presumably now i think carbon
neutrality and zero emissions and words
like this are sometimes a bit of a scam
but still not all energy is equal and
especially these large companies they
can distribute their workload across the
planet to where the energy is used most
efficiently and lastly and this i think
should really the main point here is
that we have made advances none of these
achievements here that we've made over
the past years are only scaling up the
scaling up always came with some sort of
invention that made it more efficient or
more viable to scale up residual
networks all of a sudden could scale to
many many more layers because of the
invention of the residual connection or
the addition depending on who you ask so
the residual networks became bigger and
deeper without having to waste more
computation in fact they had less
parameters than many equivalent models
of the time so i don't think we should
neglect the inventions we make along the
way in order to scale up now of course
people are always going to put in
whatever flops they have in order to
achieve the best possible number but i
think for most of these advances it was
really new inventions that triggered the
usage of these flops rather than the
other way around and the authors of
these articles actually agree a little
bit they say is it really reasonable to
extrapolate like this and extrapolating
this way would be unreasonable if we
assume that researchers would follow
this trajectory all the way to such an
extreme outcome we don't faced with
skyrocketing costs researchers will
either have to come up with more
efficient ways to solve these problems
or they will abandon working on these
problems and progress will languish
which is true so rather than being a
warning cry about we're gonna waste an
entire city's co2 emissions for a month
for one model it's more of a warning
against we're gonna have to come up with
new methods and different ways of
training these models and we can't rely
on scale to bring as advances they also
give some money numbers right here they
said for example deepmind traded system
to play go it was about 35 million
dollars on cost when they trained alpha
star they purposefully didn't try
multiple ways of architecting an
important component because the training
cost would have been too high in gpt
gpt3 they made a mistake but they didn't
fix it due to the cost of training it
wasn't feasible to retrain the model and
so on and also mentioning that gpt-3
cost about 4 million to train now yes of
course researchers that train these
giant models comes with substantial
costs so you have to think twice if you
really want to do your grid search and
whatnot so the experimentation
methodology has become a bit different
but also you have to keep in mind these
big numbers 35 million dollars 4 million
dollars and so on first of all this
isn't really that much in comparison to
what the people cost that worked on the
model and second of all this is almost
necessary all of the models that we see
today have cost substantially more in
the past to train but someone had to do
it first i can only train bert today
because google has invested ginormous
amounts of resources trying out how to
train it training the first one at
considerable cost and only after that
have other people jumped on prices have
come down training got more efficient
and now i can do it from the comfort of
my home essentially on a collab or on my
home gpu and isn't this the case with
all inventions somehow at first it's
just a few it's really expensive because
it's custom because we haven't figured
it all out yet and then over time cost
will come down efficiency will go up and
the easiness is just much better so
rather than saying oh wow deepmind spent
35 million dollars oh no i'm like cool
you know since they're doing this two
three four years i will be able to do so
for simply 2 million and hey you know so
the article gives some solutions to that
different avenues though they are mostly
a little bit pessimistic about most of
them so first of all they said you can
use specific processors designed
especially for deep learning now the
newest generations of gpus are actually
a little bit tuned to deep learning but
there are also tensor processing units
and there are a number of other hardware
vendors that try to get into the space
of specifically building chips for deep
learning what they criticize here is the
fact that this hardware has to do
trade-offs they have to increase
specialization for generality and also
with specialization you face diminishing
returns and of course the more
specialized you are the less you can
invent new things because you're
essentially locked into what the
hardware can do they also discuss
training networks that are smaller but
they criticize that often this increases
the training cost because you
essentially train a big network and then
you train again to make it smaller to
distill it and that's also not the
solution to reducing training cost but
it might be a good solution if a model
needs to be trained once and then
largely runs in inference mode such as
gpt-3 they also discuss meta learning
where you essentially train a good
initialization for a lot of problems and
then you transfer that initial solution
to new problems so if you have a good
meta learner they will be at an
excellent starting point for solving new
problems therefore reducing the training
cost in each of these new problems but
they also mentioned that and i agree
meta learning is yet at the stage where
it doesn't really work the training you
put into the initial meta learner
doesn't often pay off to new problems
yes it works in papers but in papers you
already know which other problems you're
going to measure it on so
they say even small differences between
the original data and where you want to
use it can severely degrade performance
now they also mentioned this paper right
here benjamin recht of the university of
california berkeley and others have made
this point even more starkly showing
that even with novel data sets purposely
constructed to mimic the original
training data performance drops by more
than 10 percent now i want to highlight
this a little bit because this talks
about a paper called do imagenet
classifiers generalized to imagenet this
is also usually called imagenet v2
because what these authors did is they
try to follow the protocol of the
original imagenet data collection as
closely as possible and come up with a
new test set the so-called imagenet v2
it's not a trainings that is just a test
set and they show pretty convincingly
that for any classifier that performs in
any way on imagenet v1 its performance
on imagenet v2 will be something like 10
points lower it's a fairly straight line
so this is what the article talks about
however the article doesn't talk about
this paper right here called identifying
statistical bias in date set replication
by mit and uc berkeley which shows
pretty convincingly that there is in
fact a difference between the data
collection mechanism of imagenet v1 and
v2 it is a subtle difference but there
is a difference nonetheless that
difference makes it such that there is a
significant difference in what kind of
images are chosen for the two data sets
and when you correct for that difference
then this drop in accuracy for imagenet
v2 almost entirely vanishes now okay the
article is right in first instance there
is a small difference between the
original data and the new data and that
severely degrades performance but this
particular difference in performance is
due to the new data set having a
different methodology and that directly
makes the samples harder it's not like
the samples are different in some sort
of a they're different kinds of images
is that very directly because of how
they collected them they are more
difficult to classify it's the same data
but more difficult so we shouldn't be
surprised that performance drops by 10
in this particular instance i just
thought it was interesting to mention
since the article specifically focuses
on this paper right here and i don't
think this paper is a good example of
what they're trying to say okay so
what's the conclusion to all of this
here is the final recommendation that
the article makes to evade the
computational limits of deep learning
would be to move to other perhaps as yet
undiscovered or under-appreciated types
of machine learning and of course what
they mean is that they want to bring the
insights of experts which can be much
more computationally efficient and that
we should maybe look at things like
neurosymbolic methods and other
techniques to combine the power of
expert knowledge and reasoning with the
flexibility often found in neural
networks now why does every discussion
about the scaling of deep learning
always end with well we should use more
expert systems and reasoning and logic
and the neural networks don't understand
anything now granted it is okay to
suggest this it's probably a good way
forward but as of yet as of now the
neurosymbolic systems or actually just
the expert systems as well they
are so so
not good and of course that's the case
with any young research topic but just
because something is computationally
efficient it doesn't mean that we should
switch to that because of it now i'd be
super duper happy if symbolicism makes a
comeback if we could somehow combine
algorithms and deep learning if we could
combine reasoning and knowledge bases
and input from domain experts and all of
this but as of today that is not really
a benefit it's more like a substitute so
you can make machine learning more
efficient by inputting lots and lots of
priors from domain experts that's
completely cool but what we've seen over
and over and over again is that as soon
as you give the ml system enough data it
starts to outperform these experts and i
think what i'd like to see from a
neurosymbolic system or anything like
this is that in fact it does outperform
even the most data-hungry machine
learning methods that the symbolicism is
not just a substitute for more data but
an actual improvement over any data that
i could find and that's just something
that i personally haven't seen you might
disagree but i haven't seen a convincing
argument yet that that is the case for
any of the symbolic systems we have
today computational efficiency alone is
simply not enough but hey tell me what
you think what do you think about this
article do you agree with them do you
not agree with them i'll link the full
article in the description give it a
read if you want and subscribe i'll see
you next time bye